[Music]
this is a story about a farm not just
any farm but a place where imagination
sprouts out the soil we grow really
kooky weird wild wonderful tasty stuff
honestly the weirder the better
like what mashallah oka Bajor flame beat
squash eeny butterfly sorrel sunset
sorrel Pichu berries pine berries white
alpine strawberries ice plant wait what
was the last one boy you never heard of
ice plant nope
[Music]
meet Aaron Troy Aaron never had any
intentions of getting into farming I had
actually planned to grab a masters and
then my PhD in order to teach the study
of religion and college I took a
complete 180 that 180 is thanks to his
parents after running a successful
flower shop Aaron and his sisters tried
to get them to retire but his parents
had other plans their retirement was to
go buy a farm instead they started off
growing Korean vegetables for retail
markets but then Aaron got involved and
things took a turn for the bizarre after
I got started getting my hands dirty
pulling weeds obsessing over growing
conditions light water temperature
humidity everything around it it just
became one elevated experiment after
another and I think that's where I was
hooked
and all of that ring and resonated far
better with me than sticking my nose in
books all the time quite frankly once he
familiarized himself with farm life
he took the Rd to another level we
started experimenting with a lot of
different greens then that very quickly
blew off into a whole host of other
relatively unfamiliar products like
peach berries sweet J green tomatoes
which nobody's heard of my favorites
oka and ma schewe which even fewer
people have heard of let alone actually
tasted
the goal has always been to target first
and foremost high-end restaurants
because I think that there's a lot of
trickle-down effect on new and strange
ingredients so how does one pivot from
selling bulk retail items to supplying
fancy high-end restaurants I literally
started making cold visits once the
chefs started seeing what we were
growing to my surprise they were blown
away by the quality bit I regularly get
comments like I can't believe you're
growing this tart it's the specialty
side where my obsession fits in line
with trying to familiarize the
unfamiliar there's a lot to be said
about these unfamiliar foods of the
world that we really need to introduce
more people to because the more we
popularize the more conversations happen
around those foods without food we don't
have conversation
[Music]
you